it is a great pleasure that I give you
tonight VaShawn Chakraborty good evening
everyone I know everyone is anxious to
see each other again you haven't been
with your classmates in some time but
I'd asked you to we've put a lot of work
into the speakers tonight and so I'd ask
you to kind of focus on what it is we're
doing and then there'll be plenty of
time to to talk and network that very
suspicious word in the English language
later so look so I'm the mark holiday
professor director of the program i want
to thank dana who's been such a great
supporter of ours mehul Fred for their
comments tonight columbia as Mark Wiggly
is fond of saying is a very experimental
school tonight is a great experiment the
experiment was this we hypothesized that
if we put a great event together right
had great speakers had great
opportunities for all of us to reconnect
with each other that people might
actually pay to be here and look at
worked right right so who knew but it
was a great experiment and we're so glad
that you're all here tonight we're very
thankful for showing the support that
you are all showing and spending your
evening with us in this unbelievable
extraordinary space I'd like to extend a
very special welcome that spans our 24
year history from a few of the members
of the class of 1986 so I beyond are
talking to earlier tonight and to the
class of 2010 a very special class for
me because it was my first class during
my tenure here an evening like this has
many many contributors our gala
committee mehul Fred Dana the very
expectant laura hart smith as Laura had
her baby does anyone know tomorrow
morning
alright so if you should have been here
tonight and especially to our gala chair
the wonderful very sports very special
force of nature that is Cynthia Moses
manatorian Cynthia I I really wish you
could have helped Maria and I plan our
wedding it would have gone so much more
smoothly and my gratitude the Alumni
Council the class reps the regional reps
everyone who played such a great role in
getting this crowd here tonight and
finally I just want to thank our my
colleagues are extraordinary Dean mark
Wiggly without whom none of this none of
what is happening tonight would ever
ever have been possible associate dean
Devon proven who has just always been my
partner and everything we do here hoops
they're getting to shop yet and her team
and our team led by Sarah bordy who did
an extraordinary job putting all this
together Sarah where are you thank you
Sarah and a lot of current students who
put a lot of volunteer work in can the
current student stand up Dan Debra is a
few more here Kurt we have a
I know all of you had the best class
that ever went through this program this
is one of the most extraordinary class
this is the class to watch it's the
class to beat there's a hundred and
three of them 34 hail from countries all
over the world about a third or women
they are winning competition after
competition Deborah just leading the
team that's the finalists in the chase
competition the this year the first time
we've ever reached that benchmark so I
encourage you to meet our current
students they are an extraordinary
cohort so for me and for our program
it's been an extraordinary
transformative year I had the pleasure
of meeting so many of you hearing so
many of your comments and thoughts about
this program and where it should head
where issues have been where troubles
have lurked and I've got to say in
responding to you we have with my
partner the Dean have done an
extraordinary amount today we have a
dedicated space for our students thanks
to the Dean we have a massively expanded
faculty and unrivaled course offerings
today this is a little red meat for the
crowd I had to throw this in today we
have students from the business school
beating down our door to take our
classes
we have a dedicated career development
professional Emily Griffin who's in the
crowd tonight was a great counselor for
our students we have over half of our
students traveling to brazil to India to
China to Europe to Miami it's an
emerging economy right all in January to
study real estate abroad we have a new
research project underway in partnership
with the Real Estate Board of New York
chairman of the real estate board Mary
Ann ties here called new york 2040 about
the future of New York City we have a
thriving and very feisty Alumni
Association and we have as we approach
our next application season a record set
of applicant yields which is to say that
a student who gets into our program and
gets into one of our competitors comes
here very very proud of that fact
so basically in responding to so many of
your voices we have found our own and
today I think we can state unabashedly
that given the full tuition resources we
have given the tremendous platform of
columbia university in the city of new
york that we are the best real estate
education available in the world but now
if you know Dean Wiggly and you know me
you know that the world is not of course
enough so now that we've fulfilled our
core needs our basic needs the things
that we've needed and fought for and
strove for for so long we're now
pursuing our dreams last year we
launched an expansive campaign for our
program building on the momentum that
we've had and the many new relationships
we formed all over the world we're
expanding our campaign to match our
greatest ambitions for this program the
campaign for global design and
development is a comprehensive plan to
build upon our standing as the best
development program in the world by
fostering a new model for development
research for global exchange and for a
new interdisciplinary curriculum to
accomplish this we have pledged to raise
30 million dollars for priority projects
by the end of 2013 and with that money
we will fund new research faculty new
facilities new opportunities for
scholarship and international travel new
global research hubs in the form of our
studio x network which are already
underway in China India South America
and the Middle East if you're traveling
abroad and want to understand more about
the studio X's you must visit them they
are the most incredible spaces they have
directors they represent all of G SAP
and Columbia to our best to date I am
proud to say that under Devon's great
leadership we have raised 16 million
dollars over half of that 30 million
dollar target in fact we're in
conversations that may bring us past the
20 million dollar mark by the end of the
year
now some of you in this room have played
a real true leadership role in getting
us to this point some of you will play a
leadership role to get us across the
finish line all of you who played a role
simply by being here tonight I'd like to
recognize a few of you have played
significant roles in terms of gifts this
past year to Professor Hank Bell the
great legendary Hank pal Hank where are
you where's Hank
whoo-hoo in addition to teaching I
haven't met an alumnus who doesn't tell
me Oh Hank what Hank taught me Jake Ross
one of my good friends took classes from
you I think in 1978 before there was a
program and says what Hank taught me is
what I still remember today about how to
do a performer every year Hank skank
gives to our discretionary fund and has
done a tremendous amount in supporting
the program to oxford properties which
is now run by our own Blake Hutchinson
class of 89 for student research
competition to my dear friends from
Mumbai susheela vaswani class of 03 and
his wife deepali vaswani for their
support of studio x in mumbai to stephen
Glasscock class of 91 and his wife
barbara van buren without whom we could
not be building our dedicated space in
fair weather and least but most
certainly not last to dana stone class
of 88 and her husband and industry
advisory advisory board member Andy
stone for their extraordinarily generous
leadership gift to kick off our efforts
to fund the center for global design and
development our new flagship conference
and research facility on Amsterdam
Avenue
I mentioned that Andy is on our industry
advisory board I wanted to spend a
couple of minutes on that when I first
started it was very clear to mark
holiday to Dean Wiggly to myself that
the program had to have a very select
group of industry leaders may be no more
than a dozen maybe 14 but a group that
could actually be a working group that
could get together and talk about the
future of this program and this industry
to guide us and to get out the word
about what it is we're doing here a
number of our board members are here
tonight and I had asked them to please
stand as I read their names Andy stone
CEO Petra capital
my friend and mentor Daniel L Doctoroff
president of Bloomberg LP
the tireless supporter Philip L mins
excuse me Phillip L milstein good I
screwed up that name in real estate
principle of Ogden capital properties
our great supporter Mary anti chief
executive officer CB richard ellis and
chairman of the Real Estate Board of New
York there are a few advisory board
members who are here in spirit but not
in body gene cone principal and chairman
of kpf who's represented by the
president of kpf Paul caps dan tishman
of tishman construction Howard
Rubenstein who was very much plane to be
here but is unfortunately having surgery
today I hear he's doing okay of
Rubenstein communications certainly my
mentor Stephen Ross of the related
companies
and finally one of our most prominent
alumni the chair of the board of the
industry advisory board the CEO of SL
green mark holiday now mark was looking
forward to being here he's on the
program he was psyched to be here you
got called away to London for a deal if
you know mark there is nothing that gets
between mark and a deal and so he has
instead asked me to read the following
words on his behalf please accept my
sincere apologies for not joining you
tonight I was unavoidably delayed in
returning from an overseas business trip
so I'm sending along these comments at
last year's event I had the opportunity
to reconnect with old friends meet some
of you for the first time and to talk
about the plans that were being put into
place for the program it was a great
evening with a number of key objectives
identified and the overwhelming number
of you expressed your strong support
sure enough with that support we're
making great progress just one year
later progress that's evident in a
stronger and more challenging curriculum
an exceptional student body improved
facilities energetic engagement of all
students and increased alumni
involvement through the recently
launched alumni mentoring program this
is certainly in large part thanks to the
efforts of mark Wiggly our Dean and
VaShawn and then I can't pronounce last
name who are the full-time stores of the
program they have demonstrated vision
and leadership and transforming the real
estate development program in a way that
has connected students with alumni and
industry professionals and reconnected
many alumni with the program they are
doing extraordinary does job and deserve
your appreciation thanks for being here
tonight I look forward to our continuing
efforts together now last month the
industry advisory board met for the
first time in our inaugural meeting and
my miracle worker assistant Linda
labella actually aligned the schedules
of all of these giants and all of the
industry board industry advisory board
was in attendance and you know to be
perfectly honest with you some knew
about the program some did not but
instead they were really participating
out of a sense of genuine goodwill of
camaraderie and intellectual curiosity
my basical going into that evening was
for them to have a good time enjoy each
other's company and to get to know a
little bit about all of us but much much
more happen much more transpired with
that group and a steady drumbeat kind of
emerged some said well you know there
are a few reliable sources of data in
our industry for example how does the
developer know what sustainable measures
to deploy what's the break-even analysis
why is the rest of the world so ahead of
us in infrastructure development and
construction so there was this drum beat
and it was steady and it was growing
louder and louder through the course of
the evening and it was consistently
about research it was about data it was
about the fact that we largely fly blind
in this industry and that there is not a
credible source of ongoing data as the
industry developed as building
technology emerges a sustainability
becomes at the forefront of our minds so
because we need that credible resource
axiom that credible source of research
and of data that guides us in the
practice and theory and transforms our
role in a very rapidly urbanizing world
and it was clear that that was the
mission that was put before myself and
before the Dean now if you think about
that for a second and think about what
kind of research we could be doing I was
very struck by a study I came across
that was done at the university of
chicago in two thousand and one that
basically said that fifty percent fifty
percent half of the gross domestic
product of the united states is
generated by two percent of its land
mass by west and the west of the
mississippi about four percent of its
land mass and so what does that tell you
what it basically tells you is there
some kind of equation between density
and prosperity right that if you look
out in the world today and if you look
at the places that are hurting the most
the phoenix's the Las Vegas's right
compared to the New York's and the San
Francisco's and the London's there's
clearly a correlation between vertical
density and a kind of economic ecology
that actually supports prosperity I in
fact did a quick calculation that if the
entire population of the world all six
billion of us lived at New York City
densities and i don't mean Manhattan
densities I mean all five boroughs New
York City densities that if all six
billion of us lived at that density that
we would all fit in the state of Texas
right so we sort of live in this world
of a population explosion people talk
about it by 2050 we're supposed to go to
9 billion people well that's Texas and a
little bit of New Mexico right so
liberals have a place to live too but
the point is right that vertical density
is the future it is the wave of the
future is the wave of the future all
across the planet and as we all look to
a more economically and environmentally
strategic way to live and work we will
need more vertical visit density which
means we will need more developers write
that fundamentally when you talk about
vertical density you are talking about a
professionalization of the industry and
if we need more developers and we need
smarter developers we need developers
who are conversant with the best
practices worldwide and that gets back
to the industry advisory boards mission
for us which is research that we need to
know more and this is the precise reason
that we need to build the center for
global design and development now the
generosity of Andy and Dana stone and
other impending against gifts have
launched us but we must complete this
mission the reason is simple thanks to
Stephen and Barbara and others we will
soon have a dedicated fully tricked-out
space for our students in fair weather
but we need a state of the art space for
research for a blockbuster annual
conference for executive education we
actually need this space for you we need
this space for you to return to we need
this space for you to speak in we need
you we need this space for you to skype
with and we need this space for you to
continue to learn with us